I found the neck
Institute as created and animated
Rob reamin one of the very best venues
in the world for deep and stimulating
and refreshingly unorthodox discussion
there are no boundaries to what we say
there is always an very interesting mix
of people with not only different
attitudes coming from different
countries but also different disciplines
novelists economists historians
philosophers and others and I find the
conversations always all of the ones
I've taken part in in over a number of
years to be extremely thoughts Turing
and what the world lead needs more than
anything else is a degree of new
thinking and of if you like of light and
I think the Nexxus Institute is one of
the very best institutions I'm aware of
in Europe or even in the world entire
world which provides that yes
congratulations to rob and kissed and
for what they've done in creating the
nexus Institute and keeping it going for
20 years there are so few places and so
few forums in the world in which we live
in which people have differing but
intelligent views can get together
discuss them in front of an audience who
are hungry to hear them and the Nexus to
my mind is the best example of this
partly because it's been connected with
Rob's vision of the importance of high
culture and the tradition from which
we've emerged so I just hope it goes on
forever thank you